well this week at our school batter
series we are focusing on the price of
college admission especially when you
play by the rules what you're supposed
to do well today we'll explore the
pressures parents face to get their
children into top schools in a recent
survey of almost 12,000 parents in
students seventy-three percent reported
their stress level during the college
application process was very high or
high we spoke with two moms about the
challenges
Susan Morrison from Ohio says she once
caught got caught up in the college
craze but five kids later she has some
lessons to share with other parents and
California mom Roseman Purdue says the
pressure of getting her high school
junior into college has been insane when
do your grades come out I will say that
proudly I'm a helicopter parent I was
raised during the 70s and I had 70s mom
where it was like oh oh you are you
going to school today you know it was
like whatever you want to do not be
cared and I am the opposite of that so
my oldest I pushed her and pushed her
because you're supposed to build your
resume and she was smart she turned to
me and said I can't do everything
and I really was grateful to hear that
from her because it was like I got
schooled by my kids whether they play
lacrosse look at home by the time I'm
down to my fifth he drove the whole
process himself we just kind of
understood that he's gonna be fine
whatever direction he takes the college
prep class with miss Franklin what do
you have to do to be ready it is
relentless it is constant she's got a
test prep coach
she's got test prep classes they have to
do a certain amount of volunteer hours
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
in some ways mitigate her stress
Skeeter's accused dozens of people
including two Hollywood stars of paying
millions to get their case
into top schools the biggest problem in
this particular story are the people
preyed on parents vulnerability and
built a business around cheating a
system they were Tiger moms looking to
do the best they could for their kids
and they chose a very wrong way to do it
we have to really step back and say how
can college matter enough that you'd be
willing to do these things it's an
opportunity for education the name is
not going to define your future the
school that she gets into is the school
she was meant to get into and the best
school for her is the school where she's
happy julilah Scott Haynes is a former
dean of freshman and undergraduate
advising at Stanford University she
writes about the college admissions race
in her book it's called listen to this
title how to raise an adult break free
of the overparenting trap prepare your
kids for success duly we welcome you
back - thank you morning Stanford was on
the list of one of the schools were you
surprised to hear that I think a lot of
people were surprised by the money
involved in a brazen disregard for the
law yeah I was truly shocked and that
might sound naive but what I mean by
that is having been at Stanford for 14
years and as an administrator there was
nothing in me that said anyone on that
campus was capable of accepting bribes
turns out there's one bad actor the
sailing coach who accepted some bribes
but I think of the place as being one of
filled with people full of integrity
mm-hmm let's talk about the book you I
watched your TED talk you talked about
the checklist childhood yeah right and
then you also mention I went to a state
school in Louisiana yeah right and and
I'm proud of how I turned out you should
be what were you what would you say to
parents about the fact that you can go
to a state school or a school in Oregon
like your son does yeah in turn out just
fine not only fine but happier yes but
if you went to see a Harvard right so
there's a myth in America that you have
to go to one of the US News top 20
schools to have a great life and it is
dead wrong where does that myth come
from I mean I don't subscribe to that
myth and I never did and I don't
understand why why some of my friends
felt that way I think US News and World
Report has us all in a stranglehold this
sense that you can judge a college the
way you judge a soda or a pair of jeans
or a car that brand name equals brawn
and they've sort of created this ranking
and you're like well who's at the top of
the ranking yeah if someone creates a
ranking you want to look to the top of
it they're 2,800 accredited four-year
schools in America and I will bet my
kids future on this fact the top 5% of
them that's 140 schools yes our
magnificent yes cludes most of the state
schools you can think of most of small
liberal arts colleges you can think of
and the big brand names is odd coming
from a Stanford and former Stanford
administrator that I would say that you
know to me it does not to you look I'm a
proud graduate of Stanford I'm proud to
have worked there and I'm very happy to
say to America there are plenty of great
schools yeah you're supposed to go to
the school that is the right fit for you
kids need a huge school some kids need a
small school some kids need the city
school some state kids needed countries
USA Today covered today says College
favors are wealthy you think that's true
well I think the scandal has shown us
that it's not the black and brown kids
who are stealing the spots yeah it's the
wealthy kids whose parents are snowplow
parents who are just preparing the road
for the kid instead of preparing the kid
for the road right they're doing
whatever it takes within their means to
get their kid to that future but the
question is how is that good for your
kid it's terrible for your kid okay your
kid either becomes a narcissistic
entitled brat because you've taught them
I will rig the system for you or their
mental health is completely compromised
because they've learned that you've
rigged it for them and their sense of
self is destroyed it harms them when we
over parent no doubt and let me ask you
because we've gone through this process
with my stepkids what is the role that
high school counselors play in talking
to the kids and talking to the parents
about realistically what the best school
is for their child I think these days
high school counselors can be in a real
bind particularly in schools where
parents have money and affluence the
parents is expecting I've got to get my
kid into one of these places where the
counselor knows there are so many great
schools and your kid would actually be
more likely to thrive at this school
than the one you have on the list as
working with other people's children
taught you about your own parenting when
I was a Dean of freshmen at Stanford I
worked with other people's sons and
daughters
I saw those who'd been over parented who
were reliant on their parents to choose
classes talk to professor's
resolve roommate disputes but then I saw
all the other kids who were self-reliant
and had autonomy and I thought my
goodness how do I raise my kids so they
end up like I don't like this and I
realized Gale that I was over parenting
my own kids okay I right so it's working
with other people's kids help me be a
better parent to my own to get anything
that the helicopter parents watching who
are feeling guilted right now the one
thing they can do to make a change
absolutely there's something I call the
one-week cleanse if you're the sort of
parent who by the way parents who /
parent in this manner are often doing it
for their own ego yes right these
parents they've got everything they need
financially why do they need their kid
to go to one of these big brand-name
schools for their own ego okay so if
that's you if you need if you're on your
kid constantly you need to know what
grades they got today how they did in
the science test what kind of homework
they have the one-week cleanse is this
you go to your kid and you say hey kid I
know I'm always on you I know I'm always
nagging you about your grades and scores
and that can make you feel that I don't
think you care but I know you do care so
for one week I'm gonna button it I'm not
gonna ask you about those things parents
tell me there's more laughter in the
homes the parent-child relationship is
healthier and happier because you're
talking about life not about the
academic transact that says more you're
making your kid feel they matter to you
because they exist thank you
[Laughter]
thank you our school matters the price
of admission series continues tomorrow
you're watching CBS this morning we're
going to talk to former you phen
associate dean Sarah hay Burson she's
pulling back the curtain on the
admissions process and offers tips on
what schools are actually looking for